but did I know kinda go live I hear
nothing I'm just gonna tell you what I
know I had looked on Instagram Toni and
Trina half said this is my stepson
now whatever hits Trevor I might
shredded I jumped upon her stepson
trained a hat he looked it yes she did
dizzy why is you on the Grande Punto
somebody go step sign and you ain't
married to they've all them so that's
really important to me that we throw
Trina a big party this year like we all
just reconnected and it's just really
important that we heal this sisterly
bond you know I'm saying and most
importantly I need to know is she went
off and elope with her beau I'm just
since that you know she up did that bag
and you know I got especially for things
like this let me show you happy 22nd
birthday to my stepson we should tell us
[Music]
the shoes you hear the purses they have
I didn't tell her Tamara's cuckoo okay
she's nuts
she's really convinced that B and I are
married and now Trina and who's next -
Wanda mommy I don't think they're
married I just I don't believe it that's
the virus one out of my closet or one
out of your okay yes okay of your choice
yeah choice done that pew Vicki goodbye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]